I'm Laura Ingram everyone this is the
Ingram angle thank you for being with us
Invasion By Invitation that's the focus
of tonight's angle
[Music]
a couple of things that made me laugh
and cry over the past few days first
what made me laugh
is not open that is that is something
that that is uh peddled as a talking
point but it's not true there are fences
there are walls there are border patrol
agents who work on the border
well the regime media is really working
overtime for the big guy it reminds me
of Iraq State media back in the day
we crushed the forces in Saddam
International Airport
and we cleaned the whole place of the
airport
yeah Baghdad Bob would be proud of the
whole Pro Biden crew
just like the Iraqi troops were clearing
the airport the Biden team is clearing
the Border no problem
work to remove as quickly as possible
those who do not
intensely than ever before by arresting
and Prosecuting them disrupting and
dismantling their networks and seizing
their properties and funds
I like how they couldn't make it well
either they didn't want anyone to hear
this now what's really telling is that
things are going so well at the border
that they're leaning on the last regime
to boost the new regime
it was a good thing that uh the
Department of Homeland Security decided
to grant TPS to about 9 500 Venezuelans
here in the city that will expedite
their ability to get jobs sooner and
faster but that's really just a drop in
the bucket
well that's former Obama DHS Chief Jay
Johnson well he did go on to call the
Border a problem with no end in sight
but remember their answer for the
problem is just more immigration just
wave them all in work permits and soon a
fast track to voting
now the gravity of this assault on our
sovereignty and a rule of law
it's kind of hard to overstate and the
angle is using the term assault by the
way for accuracy not for hyperbole
because remember what we see unfolding
at the border right now is not the
result of a failed Biden policy this is
their policy it's an invasion by
invitation
now in the past 24 hours or so alone
there were approximately 11
000 migrants tracked at the Southwest
border
so sleepy Joe keeps breaking records wow
but not the kind any of us want
poor folks in Eagle Pass Texas they're
reeling their four thousand from Friday
through Sunday alone yeah four thousand
migrants so to get a sense of of what
this really means the perspective here
remember the Martha's Vineyard bleeding
hearts couldn't even deal with 50
illegals who were sent there that was
too much you know Fast Track them over
to Boston
and Democrats idea of addressing the
Border crisis is to just make it worse
Kathy hokel in New York is calling in
the National Guard
but only to help deal with what she
calls case management
I.E getting them their work permits as
soon as possible
in practice by the way the work permits
the temporary protective status that
amounts to permanent amnesty we talked
about that last week with Stephen Miller
and it's all being done without a single
vote cast all done by executive Fiat
how diabolical these people are
the White House sabotages the border so
they can then come in and force Amnesty
on Millions to address the crisis that
they created
again all foisted upon the American
public without their approval nobody
wants this
all right now you're wondering what made
me cry well this photo
my orcas and the Biden globalists treat
our border patrol like sacrificial Lambs
this is what happens to the brave men
and women who are actually trying their
very best to protect us under impossible
circumstances
it makes you cry for them
Makes You Weep for our country
Democrats wanted us all to believe that
January 6 was really almost the end of
America
there were some criminals obviously we
talked about at the time who needed
Prosecuting for sure that day but
nothing compares to the coast to coast
Devastation that is being caused by
Biden's purposeful opening of our border
a legal is committing vile crimes even
murder
and others busted for DUI like this
upstanding individual a 28 year old
named Lenny Rodriguez Cruz who allegedly
rammed an NYPD squad car then bit off a
piece of a Sergeant's finger while he
was in a holding cell
I guess we're supposed to feel sorry for
this freak because he's being described
as emotionally disturbed
so every murder every rape every injury
to an innocent American every tax dollar
spent on an illegal every child
trafficked every cartel Kingpin who
collects his next million
all of it all of it is on Biden and the
Democrats
and that's the angle hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else